♪ ♪
>> Greg: CNN'S CUE BALL OF
CONCERN, BRIAN STELTER, SLAM
DONALD TRUMP FOR SKIPPING THIS
YEAR'S CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER.
>> IN THE PAST, PRESIDENT HAVE
SHOWN UP EVEN IF THEY'RE ANGRY
AND DEPRESSED.
IT'S USEFUL FOR WHITE HOUSE
AIDES TO SCHMOOZE WITH
REPORTERS.
IT'S HELPFUL FOR US TO GET TO
KNOW OUR SOURCES.
THERE IS VALUE IN THESE EVENTS.
IT'S YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF WHAT
WE ARE SEEING, THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ATTACK AGAINST
THE MEDIA.
IT TAKES MANY FORMS.
>> Greg: 'S ARE NOW SKIPPING A
DINNER IS AN ATTACK ON THE
MEDIA?
BRIAN IS TAKING THIS ATTACK ON
THE PRESS SHTICK TO CRAZY
HEIGHTS.
NO OFFENSE BUT MAY BE SKIPPING A
MEAL NOW AND THEN MIGHT NOT BE A
BAD THING FOR SOME PEOPLE IN THE
PRESS.
I INCLUDE MYSELF.
THAT'S WHY I'M WALKING MORE,
JESSE.
AS FOR SCHMOOZING, BEING USEFUL,
NO, FOR US THIS DINNER IS JUST
AN ORGY.
SWEATY LEMMINGS, PEERING OVER
THEIR SHOULDER TO SEE WHO MIGHT
STUMBLE INTO THE STINKING,
OVERCROWDED MESS HALL.
THE HALITOSIS IS SO THICK YOU
COULD CUT IT WITH A CAKE KNIFE.
SOME SAY TRUMP'S AVOIDANCE HAS
COMMON SENSE.
WHY GO TO A PLACE WHEN THE
ENTIRE THEME WILL BE ORANGE MAN,
BAD.
THE SAME PLATITUDES EXPRESSED BY
THE SAME --
HERE'S A THOUGHT.
WHY NOT HIRE HOST WHO DOESN'T
APPEAR AT THE PREDICTABLE JOKES.
IMAGINE JORDAN PETERSON, JOE
ROGAN, DAVE RUBIN.
THAT'S THE REAL COWARD, BEING
AFRAID TO CHALLENGE THE MEDIA
MOB ORTHODOXY.
GREG IS FOR CHARITY, TRUE.
BUT BY SKIPPING THE DINNER,
TRUMP HAS STRIPPED AWAY THE
NOVELTY THAT HAS CHANGED THE
CHARITY EVENT.
HE MADE IT GREAT AGAIN.
IT'S NOW ABOUT JOURNALISM.
IN ORDER THEY ARE MISERABLE.
DANA, DO YOU KNOW THIS EVENT, IT
SUPPOSED TO BE FOR CHARITY AND
THAT'S GOOD BUT IT BECAME EVENTS
FOR PEOPLE LIKE AVENATTI, THE
FLAME OF THE MOMENT, THAT WOULD
SHOW UP.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW PEOPLE WHO
WOULD INVITE AVENATTI.
YOU KNOW THEM VERY WELL.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
I WENT SIX YEARS IN A ROW WITH
THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION.
I'M NOT A NIGHT OWL.
I DID LIKE TO SEE THE FOLKS.
I DID LIKE TO SEE PEOPLE.
IT WAS FUN.
IT WAS ALWAYS COLDER THAN YOU
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE.
YOU DRESS UP IN YOUR MISERABLE.
HE'S NOT COMING TO THE DINNER.
LET IT GO.
ALSO THEY DO HAVE A POINT.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE'S JUST SKIPPING
THE DINNER.
HE'S GOING TO GO TO A RALLY AND
SAY I CAME HERE INSTEAD OF BEING
WITH THEM AND HE'S GOING TO
ATTACK THE MEDIA.
>> Greg: IT IS WIN-WIN.
THEY GET TO SULK AND HE GETS TO
LOOK AT PEOPLE SULKING.
IT'S LIKE THEY GOT STOOD UP FOR
THE PROM.
>> Jesse: THEY RUINED THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT'S
DINNER PARTY AND NOW THEY ARE
COMPLAINING THAT TRUMP IS NOT
GOING.
THEY HAVE BEEN BRUTAL TO HIM AND
HE DOESN'T CARE ANYMORE.
THIS THING PEAKED A LONG TIME
AGO.
USED TO HAVE BETTER CELEBRITIES
AND BETTER CELEBRITIES.
I WANT TO GO PLAYERS AGO, IT
PROBABLY PEOPLE THEN.
NOW I DON'T GO ANYMORE.
OUT OF RESPECT, YOU SHOULDN'T
REALLY TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE'S
PHYSICAL CHARACTERISTICS.
I AM ABOVE ALL OF THAT.
I WOULD NEVER DO ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
I DON'T LIKE WHEN GROWN MEN SEEM
SO CONCERNED AND UPSET ABOUT
THINGS.
IT'S LIKE YOU ARE A GROWN MAN.
CONSTANTLY OFFENDED.
WHAT GROWN MEN DO YOU KNOW THAT
ARE CONSTANTLY FUNDED?
>> Emily: WHO ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
>> Jesse: THE GUY ON CNN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: A JUAN, THE GOOD NEWS
ABOUT THE EVENT IS THEY ARE
HAVING A HISTORIAN --
SO IT'S GOING BACK TO ITS ROOTS.
ONCE AGAIN, DONALD TRUMP HAS
IMPROVED SOMETHING.
>> Juan: IS THAT RIGHT?
>> Greg: HE HAS MADE THE
CORRESPONDENCE AND A GREAT
AGAIN.
ARE YOU GOING?
>> Juan: I GO USUALLY.
I HAVEN'T FOLLOWED, I HAVE TO
CHECK IT OUT.
I'VE BEEN INVITED TO A BUNCH OF
PARTIES.
MY FEELING IS I AGREE WITH WHAT
DANA IS SAYING.
I THINK HE USES THAT TO PLAY TO
RIGHT WING GRIEVANCES.
THE PRESIDENT IS SO EVIL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT HE
DOES, HE IS LIKE THE NONSENSE
REGURGITATE HER.
HE TAKES WHAT YOU SAY AND SPITS
IT OUT AND IT MEAN SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
>> Juan: I HEARD HIM SAY THAT
HE'S GONNA GO TO THE RALLIES AND
SAM HERE WITH YOU AND NOT OF THE
EVIL PEOPLE AT THE PRESS.
HE SAYS FAKE NEWS, AND IT TURNS
OUT ACCORDING TO THE MUELLER
REPORT COME HE'S TELLING MORE
LIES ABOUT THE NEWS AND THE
MEDIA IS TELLING.
>> Jesse: NO COLLISION, HOW IS
THAT?
>> Juan: OH, I WASN'T TRYING
TO FIRE JIM COMEY.
>> Greg: IT'S ABOUT THE
CORRESPONDENCE DINNER.
EMILY, ARE YOU NEW -- WOULD YOU
GO?
>> Emily: I AM NOT ATTENDING.
>> Greg: YOU WILL MISS GETTING
HIT ON BY JEFFREY TOBIN.
>> Emily: HE MADE IT SOUND AS
-- MADE IT SOUND EXCITING.
STELTER FOCUSES ON, WHY WOULD HE
CARE SO MUCH.
HE SAYS THE TWO REASONS TO COME
ARE TO CELEBRATE THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND RAISE MONEY
FOR THE SCHOLARSHIP.
ATTENDING DOES NOT PRECLUDE
EITHER OF THOSE AND HE SAYS HE
CELEBRATES THE FIRST AMENDMENT
DAILY WITH HIS REPORTING.
>> Jesse: SCHMOOZING WITH
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS.
>> Dana: IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT SAID NO ONE FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE WILL GO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE FROM